question battling over the economy the
pandemic and president rodrigo duterte's
policies they debate in front of a live
audience who has the best plan for the
country's future
manila mayor isco moreno senator panfilo
luxon and vice president leni robredo
are among the crowd favorites
out of 118. out of the 118
infrastructure plans of president
duterte only 12 have been finished we
need to rebuke them and instead get the
filipino private sector as partners also
focusing less on infrastructure and
going beyond like linking farms to
market roads
known around the world for his boxing
career manny pacquiao is now a senator
promising to provide housing for all
filipino families but he hasn't exactly
laid out how he plans to achieve that
just like manny pacquiao manila mayor
istory
is quintessentially filipino he was a
poor kid who became an actor he went on
to become one of manila's most popular
mayors
moreno doubled down on that rags to
riches story saying anything is possible
if he becomes president
vice president leni robredo is the
leader of the opposition and the only
female candidate in this year's run-up
let us not look for the ones who are not
here i am always here all the time in
front of you
fighting for you
true leaders show up and man up
the best man for the job is a woman mr
marcos will not be joining this debate
robredo is referring to this empty
podium it was meant for bongbong marcus
jr son of the late dictator ferdinand
marcus senior and a front-runner in the
elections but he has refused to attend
nearly all debates since the campaign
started he says the questions have been
repetitive and are lacking in substance
some of those questions include his
conviction for tax evasion his family's
multi-million dollar estate tax and
accusations over drugs use
even his own supporters have urged him
to show up saying leaders should have
the courage to face the public compared
to previous debates the insults hurled
towards each other are less personal
but as the hours dragged on the show
started to look more like an emergency
meeting for a country deeply in crisis
in this key moment of a long and
divisive campaign nearly all the
candidates agree that debates are a
necessary opportunity for the voters to
measure the candidates credibility
jamella allendogen al jazeera manila